what like for you uh growing up in
Puerto Rico what was like uh the
American artist that like you kind of
grew up listening to that maybe helped
kind of form some of your style outside
of the Spanish stuff I listened to a lot
of people like Chris Brown
Casey and JoJo Boyz II Men uh
uh damn a lot this I love you for
Rihanna Neo
I remember Neil was like one of the
biggest yeah I mean his pen game's crazy
yeah he's one of the best songwriters of
all yeah exactly
um so yeah yeah a lot of people I listen
to a lot of people and and obviously I
don't know how I mold myself to like be
Jay Willard with listening to all of
them so being inspired by by them so so
yeah but yeah I listen to a lot of
people
um how hip are like like it's crazy to
see like uh like Mexican artists having
this huge wave right now like peso Puma
is so huge it is and it happened like
super quick like were you hip to like
what he had been had like had going on
for a while because it just seems like
I just woke up one day and peso pluma
was like the biggest [__] yeah no I
didn't happen fast I didn't realize I
mean I realized one song was like the
one that says
when I listened to that song I was like
okay who is this guy that was the first
time I heard him after that it was over
it's yeah I listened to him like I mean
I I seen him and I listened to him and I
take talk everywhere he's everywhere
he's one of the biggest artists I think
right now so I don't know how it
happened is like the Mexican stuff
hitting in in like a place like Puerto
Rico at all I mean because it's
different it's obviously totally
different music I mean we we as artists
have tried to like put it there but yeah
I think I think now because of what
people's best of luma and bad bunny is
doing with the Grupo Frontera I think
this is the name
um yeah I think Puerto Rico started to
like get the flow of the the missing
music but yeah I feel good songs yeah I
feel like Puerto Rican music like I was
see reggae's home like music out of
Puerto Rico uh the Dr has like Mexico's
embraced it you know what I'm saying
like if you go to Mexico like that's
what they're playing on on the boats
yeah yeah exactly so I was just
wondering if like they like Mexican
music had a crossover moment I mean the
other direction yeah some of the songs
like the biggest songs yeah in Puerto
Rico yeah they're they're they're
somewhere that's dope uh you just so
you're recently married yes which is
dope your wife's here she brought your
French Bulldog yeah what's your French
bulldog's name Lilo is Lilo I got two
dogs I got Lilo and I got a new Finland
uh just won a big dog just can't travel
as easy exactly and he's in training
right now he's called Apollo like what
are you getting him trained for just
like sitting to be a service dog oh okay
okay yeah so then you could take them on
the plane exactly that's my whole point
yeah you know they sell the Amazon
little vest for the dogs that aren't
like I mean it's kind of the
we tried it and it didn't work oh it
didn't oh you already tried it yeah we
tried a whole bunch of things so like
get the fact that she's here is a
surprise because they almost not let us
bring her here yeah she's not a service
dog I mean she's she is now but we don't
have the papers on them well you don't
want her on um you don't want that dog
to be in the bottom of the plane you got
to carry the dog exactly no no obviously
yeah because of the way I don't want
none of my dogs no no none of my dogs
you might have to buy a a seat for the
big dog though yeah exactly yeah I don't
mind